Traduttore: Marianna Gusmeroli
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Grazie.
Sono molto contenta
di condividere con voi
la mia esperienza di cambiamento
nell'ambito professionale in cui opero,
cioè la storia dell'arte,
e in particolare
la lettura dell'immagine.
Va premesso che
il mio primo incontro
con le opere d'arte
avvenne nell'ingresso
della casa dei nonni.
Lì c'erano sei quadretti
di paesaggio,
che erano 30 centimetri
per 18 di altezza, circa,
e la cosa interessante era
che spesso venivano sostituiti.
Ora chiaramente penserete
"ma che straordinari collezionisti
erano i suoi nonni?"
Ebbene sì, confermo.
Erano degli straordinari collezionisti,
soprattutto nonna Luigia,
ma di coperchi
di scatole di cioccolatini.
Sua sorella,
la zia Ernesta,
ogni Natale le mandava
una scatola di cioccolatini
che aveva una riproduzione
di un'opera d'arte sul coperchio.
Se la riproduzione
era un quadro di paesaggio
allora avrebbe avuto l'onore
di essere messo in cornice.
La nonna coinvolgeva anche me
nella scelta del paesaggio da sostituire,
perché rigorosamente
dovevano essere sei
i quadretti all'ingresso.
Certamente vi chiederete
"Ma quale straordinaria capacità critica
avranno mai avuto una signora
che aveva fatto la seconda elementare
e una bambina di quattro o cinque anni?"
Eppure per noi era una cosa serissima.
Con la lente d'ingrandimento
si guardavano i piccoli dettagli,
si valutavano la luce e il colore,
e a nessuna delle due, vi assicuro,
è mai venuto in mente
che in realtà noi stavamo guardando
delle banali,
forse anche malriuscite riproduzioni.
Eppure sono convinta
che devo proprio a nonna Luigia
l'interesse e la passione,
forse un po' anche l'ossessione
per la lettura dell'opera d'arte.
Immagini che, chiaramente,
una volta arrivata al liceo,
ho capito essere dei quadri
che stavano nei musei,
essere in tanti posti,
soprattutto gli originali,
non, certamente,
nell'ingresso della casa dei nonni.
Al liceo, a dir la verità,
c'è stato il primo cambiamento,
perché le immagini
che ho iniziato a guardare
erano riprodotte sul manuale
di storia dell'arte.
Il mio vecchio manuale di storia dell'arte
conteneva immagini patinate meravigliose.
Una decina erano a colori.
La maggior parte era in bianco e nero.
Provate a pensare quale sforzo
una studentessa liceale doveva fare
per immaginare davanti
ad una fotografia in bianco e nero
i colori della volta
della Cappella Sistina,
di un quadro di Caravaggio,
di Kandinskij, di Pollock.
Qualche anno fa ho ripreso in mano
il mio testo di storia dell'arte,
quel vecchio manuale,
e ho trovato un appunto
di fianco a un abito
di una Madonna
in una scena della Natività.
Diceva questo:
"Rosa ciclamino sbiancato dalla luce".
Non avevo scritto "rosa",
no, "rosa ciclamino".
"Rosa ciclamino" vuol dire
che quel rosa è carico di emozione,
perché vuol dire
i ciclamini del bosco, il profumo,
vuol dire l'effetto tattile delle foglie.
Insomma, io al liceo ho capito una cosa:
che l'opera d'arte,
guardare l'opera d'arte
educa all'immaginazione.
E soprattutto che guardare l'opera d'arte
è un passaggio assolutamente fondamentale,
perché permette al nostro cervello
di creare dei collegamenti.
Ed è con questa convinzione
che sono andata avanti negli studi,
ho frequentato l'università,
e in un'aula buia
i miei occhi e la mia mente
si immergevano a guardare
quel fascio colorato
che dal proiettore andava su un telo,
e mi immergevo
in quelle straordinarie opere d'arte.
Opere d'arte che poi, chiaramente,
andavo a ricercare sui libri.
Talvolta, anche, mi capitava
di arrivare davanti all'opera d'arte
con un senso di attesa
evidentemente straordinario.
Ed è così che sono approdata,
30 fa, a insegnare storia dell'arte.
E qui un altro cambiamento.
Un altro cambiamento perché,
evidentemente, dovevo insegnare
ad altri a leggere le opere d'arte.
Da giovane insegnante di arte
avevo un'unica convinzione:
che bisognava mettere gli allievi
davanti alle immagini,
anche se erano delle immagini riprodotte.
E fu così che iniziai,
30 anni fa, appunto,
a fare lezione in un'aula
che gi studenti
ribattezzarono "il pullman".
Avete presente l'interno
di un pullman anni '80?
C'era una stanza
che era l'archivio, a scuola,
due metri di larghezza
per cinque di lunghezza.
Due file parallele di sedie,
uno stretto corridoio in mezzo,
tende nere,
un proiettore alle loro spalle,
e davanti a loro, come se fosse
il parabrezza, appunto, di un pullman
si proiettavano le immagini
delle opere d'arte.
È chiaro che i loro occhi
si spalancavano
davanti a quelle straordinarie immagini.
E l'ora settimanale di storia dell'arte
era un momento di immersione totale
in luci e colori.
Ed è così che, pian piano,
educavo la loro immaginazione.
Valutavano anche in un modo critico,
chiaramente, le opere.
Ora è certo, non mi serve più
andare in anticipo a scuola
per selezionare le diapositive
da mettere nel carrello.
Ora anch'io uso il powerpoint
e lì le immagini sono già ordinate.
Se non trovo un'immagine non c'è problema:
internet me la dà tranquillamente.
Oggi con i ragazzi si va spesso in giro,
si vedono tantissime opere,
in Italia, in Europa.
Bene, direte.
È arrivata alla conclusione.
I cambiamenti tecnologici
oggi ci danno la tranquillità assoluta
di non aver bisogno di immaginare.
Tanto basta un clic,
e anche quello che non abbiamo
davanti ai nostri occhi ci appare.
Ma siamo proprio sicuri?
Che non abbiamo bisogno di immaginare?
Di immaginare un rosa ciclamino
mentre i nostri occhi stanno guardando
una foto in bianco e nero?
Perché, per conoscere,
bisogna immaginare.
E se è vero quello che sosteneva Einstein,
che la conoscenza è limitata,
l'immaginazione invece abbraccia il mondo,
allora dobbiamo continuare
a educare a immaginare,
la nostra immaginazione.
Lo scorso dicembre
ho vissuto un'esperienza
che mi ha confermato
che l'opera d'arte,
e l'arte, sono sicuramente
degli strumenti particolarmente potenti
per educare l'immaginazione.
Anzi, ho avuto un'esperienza
che mi ha detto
che siamo un po' tutti dei non vedenti.
Si trattava di un incontro,
di un progetto,
realizzato dall'Associazione
Nazionale Ipovedenti di Milano,
che si intitola "Descrivedendo".
Era una sorta di sfida
lanciata a noi vedenti,
perché dovevamo trovare
immagini e parole
per raccontare, per descrivere
un'opera d'arte.
L'opera d'arte scelta
era quella di De Chirico,
una scena di gladiatori di De Chirico.
Quella descrizione iniziava così.
Per cominciare,
immaginiamo un grande dipinto,
di forma rettangolare,
con il lato più lungo in orrizzontale,
alto come una persona di media statura,
e largo come un lenzuolo
matrimoniale steso.
Riusciamo ad immaginarlo?
Siete riusciti a vederlo?
Forse se chiudiamo gli occhi sì.
Vorrei che chiudeste un attimo gli occhi,
per provare l'emozione che ho provato io,
appunto, lo scorso dicembre.
Allora chiudiamo gli occhi
e iniziamo a immaginare di vedere
uno dei tre cavalli dipinti da De Chirico,
quello che sta in mezzo,
in piedi.
Non è un cavallo molto grande,
anzi sembra più un pony.
Sulla sinistra ha una coda gigantesca,
voluminosa, riccia.
Ecco, allunghiamo un attimo la mano.
La riusciamo a toccare,
dà la stessa sensazione di quando
ci passiamo una mano tra i capelli.
Il quadro è chiaramente
molto più complicato di un cavallo,
anche perché questo cavallo
è in un groviglio di corpi nudi
di uomini, di gladiatori, appunto.
Anzi, riapriamo gli occhi
e vediamolo, questo quadro.
Capite che, ora farete pure fatica
a cercarlo, questo cavallo.
È chiaro, la descrizione
era durata un quarto d'ora.
Noi abbiamo guardato
questo quadro per un secondo.
Ma vi posso assicurare che,
dopo quel quarto d'ora di descrizione,
davanti, semplicemente, a un telo,
anche chi è abituato a leggere le immagini
aveva vissuto un'esperienza sensoriale
e immaginativa del tutto straordinaria.
Ecco, adesso sì, sono arrivata
alla conclusione.
Che cosa è per me, allora, il cambiamento?
Per me il cambiamento significa
guardare un'opera d'arte
con gli occhi di una persona ipovedente.
Cioè avere un nuovo, diverso
punto di vista da cui guardare il mondo.
In fondo, cambiare
significa proprio questo:
avere un altro punto di vista,
immaginare qualche cosa
che non riusciamo neanche a concepire.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Scusate.
Prima di lasciarvi volevo
assolutamente ringraziare
Catherine de Senarclens, perché
non sarei mai salita su questo palco
se non ci fosse stata lei,
che mi ha dato anche
il suggerimento iniziale
per questa nostra conversazione.
Grazie mille.
(applausi)